we actually saw Christine Nets last
night at the Hollywood premiere I'm a
star is born
Keltie night first on the red carpet
where it was Bradley Cooper and of
course Lady Gaga's time to shine and
shine dishy
at if you had the veil moment and I
thought is there any possibility you can
top this
and tonight a train a cape tell me what
went into this love I just had a vision
for silver lace chiffon she did a
beautiful job the whole Gaga's full
transformation into a silver screen
siren
[Music]
the gallon also paid tribute to one of
Barbra Streisand's dresses in the 1976
adaptation I tell you this one caught me
by surprise
that wasn't the only nod to the film's
rich Hollywood legacy be here at the
shrine where the Judy Garland version
was filmed that there's still so much
history yeah I mean it just always felt
like this was the place to have it and
also the fact that Judy Garland sat on
that stage and there's a whole 20-minute
interlude in the meat middle of that
movie that's all at the shrine
what does this mean to you to hear
critics and fans across the world say
that you're a revelation in this role
I'm just extremely humbled and grateful
Bradley is an visionary
I loved singing with him as well his
voice is beautiful maybe it's down with
Leo
now that you know you're such a singer
do you find yourself singing more
lullabies like Russian children music
that's that's what's playing in our
house these days so I am singing along
to that quite often yeah
[Music]
[Applause]